foreign
[Music]
at the White House this week President
Clinton officially came out against
same-sex marriages what's more the
president said he is not too crazy about
opposite sex marriages either
it's been 23 years since Saturday Night
Live fired Norm Macdonald from his
weekend update position a decision that
to this day remains as one of the most
bizarre stories in comedy history
involving Don omire Norm Macdonald and
O.J Simpson well it is finally official
murder is legal in the state of
California
Norm Macdonald joined the cast of
Saturday Night Live in 1993 and just one
year later was already hosting the
show's popular Weekend Update segment at
the age of 35. a new airport planned for
San Diego would actually be located
three miles out in the Pacific Ocean
built on 40 by 20 foot floating
cylinders it's all part of a plan by
City officials to have a huge disaster
a French man who calls himself the snake
man was arrested this week after
climbing up the side of a Manhattan
high-rise yep he climbed right up the
side of a high-rise just like a snake
considered by many to be the best
Weekend Update host SNL has ever had
Norm's extremely unique sense of humor
was on full display in this role as he
reported each week's current news cycle
with his signature twist
my farewell performance over the course
of his four years on air Norm joked on
everything that was happening in the mid
90s from sporting events to Global
Affairs but there was one specific topic
that Norm loved to joke about the most
so often in fact it ended up costing him
his job and the pope came out with a
book this week which contains a series
of essays examining faith and morality
in today's secular world and the
changing role of the Catholic Church as
it approaches the 21st century the book
is entitled God himself told me that OJ
is guilty
in other book news Prince Charles
released an autobiography in which he
states that he never loved Princess Di
and that his father pressured him to
marry her the book is entitled of course
OJ did it I mean come on
in his book O.J Simpson says that he
would have taken a bullet or stood in
front of a train for Nicole man I'm
going to tell you that is some bad luck
when the one guy who would have died for
you kills you
foreign
announced this week that he's coming out
with a new book called I want to tell
you and if it's successful OJ will work
on yet another book entitled from
football to prison my 25 years of
showering with other men
you don't mind if I ask you a question
I'm here today I hear the story and
others like this press release so you
get your ass fired is that yeah no you
didn't get fired yeah they fired no they
didn't fire him no I'm serious I talked
to a guy that said I'm fired now why
would they fire you well uh I fired you
first of all let's get some names here
let's get this on the record well I
don't know the guys like because the
guys I work with I Lauren Michaels and
stuff did Lauren Michaels fire you no he
didn't he didn't fire me he likes me and
stuff well it's his show isn't it I
thought it was for sure yeah but uh well
then how can a guy come in from the
outside and fire you somebody from ABC
fired no no they're NBC what happens is
your work on the show and then there's
these guys that hang out like in the
Halls yeah we got them here we've got
the hill we got them here and they're
called Executives they're NBC Executives
right and then I'd see him I didn't know
who the hell they were what they did you
know now I know what they do they fire
me for Weekend Update but they said that
this guy Don olmeyer turns out to be the
president yeah now I know Don olmeyer
and just between you and me he's an
idiot oh
so he goes uh oh yeah I'm uh I'm firing
you there from the show and then I I
said uh oh that's not good yeah and then
I said why is that now and he goes uh oh
you're not you know you're not funny
yeah and then I said uh I said holy Lord
that's even worse news you know did you
do something to this guy did you bust
into his house or something no I didn't
do it I don't understand first of all
yeah because I get kind of depressed
sometimes because this guy he's best
friends with O.J Simpson right right
yeah is that true are they best friends
yes they're best friends they hang out
this guy they play golf yes now
how can he not like me yeah
Saturday Night Live firing a comedian
for telling jokes might sound insane but
it's actually something that's happened
for years to some of their most talented
cast members including not only Norm but
also Adam Sandler Chris Rock and most
recently Shane Gillis oddly enough three
out of the four of those guys went on to
host their own episode of SNL in the
Years following their firings I was
fired
fired I was fired so sad to tell well I
never saw it coming
I got fired from SNL damn I was hosting
and there was three guys I've never
hosted them how many times have you left
one time it was a mistake did it not go
well it was that right did you do update
yeah
after I got fired from update I thought
it'd be funny
there was three there were three uh uh
guys doing music you know and I don't
know music I just know old music like
again Lauren would go who do you like
and I go you like the you know this guy
uh Bobby Goldsboro
[Laughter]
everyone else knew except me it was
Snoop Dogg he just changed his name and
he was angry because I kept getting it
wrong it used to be Snoop Doggy Dog the
Snoop Dogg and Eminem and Dr Dre so it's
a pretty heavy lineup yeah but to me it
was two black guys and a white guy
if he player asked me to do the show you
know I gotta say I felt kind of weird
you know I don't know if you remember
this but I used to actually be on this
show you know I used to do the Weekend
Update news routine you remember that
and uh
[Applause]
that's where I did the make-believe news
jokes you know that was me right so then
a year and a half ago right I had a sort
of a disagreement with the management at
uh at the NBC uh I wanted to keep my job
right
and they felt the exact opposite
so
so you see they like they fired me
because they said that I wasn't funny
you know now now with most jobs I could
have had a hell of a lawsuit on my hands
for that but but see this is a comedy
show so they got me you know you know
you know what but now it's a weird part
right it's only a year and a half later
and now they asked me to host the show
so I wondered I go hey wait a second
here hey
I don't know how did I go in a year and
a half from being not funny enough to be
even allowed in the building
to being so funny that I'm now hosting
the show
how did I suddenly get so damn funny
it was inexplicable to me because a year
and a half let's face is not enough time
for a dude to learn how to be fun
Dan it occurred to me I haven't gotten
funnier the show has gotten really bad
so yeah I'm funny compared to you know
how well you'll see later but
okay so let's recap
the bad news is
I'm still not funny
the good news is the show blows
all right folks we got a bad show for
you tonight Dr Dre Snoop Doggy Dog and
Eminem are here
so in the end there's two main takeaways
from this video number one Don Omar is a
for firing one of the funniest
people to ever live and number two you
should subscribe to joke World thanks
for watching
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out